Hello the internet you've
joined us very late at night and
Shh
Shh keep the noise down for the neighbors.
David is sleeping.
And in this video,
we're gonna experiment with
different colored flames.
So there are multiple ways to
change the color of a flame.
And we're gonna use tiki oil.
Tiki stuff.
Just lamp oil.
Basically when we were doing
the fire breathing video,
I noticed that you can buy
these in different colors.
So we've got blue and green tiki oil,
we've also got red,
and we're gonna use just normal
orange color flames as well.
Yeah.
Just a regular bog standard flame.
Bog standard flame.
And we're gonna see if we
get some nice, you know,
different colored shots.
Then maybe merge them together.
A little bit of a rainbow flame.
Sounds good to me.
Alright, let's whip out the Phantom.
Filming high speed in the
dark is insanely difficult.
You can't see anything
but we'll see how it goes.
Let's heat things up a little bit.
Anymore.
It's longer than the actual
I feel like [Inaudible 00:01:04]
must be cold.
pulling out like a big
worm from someone's leg.
You know as you did
pulling worms out of legs.
Well you know like parasite worms.
Yeah.
For some green Tiki.
What colors the fluid?
Is it green?
No, it's actually clear.
The blue tiki one was
slightly blue tinge to it
But this, this is clear.
Okay, so we're gonna turn
off the lights before we go
to avoid any flickering in the image
and shoot all this in 4k at
a thousand frames a second.
It's incredibly difficult
to predict where the focus is going to be.
So we'll probably use a little
pilot light from the propane.
I'll try and see it.
It's gonna be so dull 1000
frames a second at night
but yeah,
I'll do my best.
Your dull.
Yep, hit it.
Okay, let's test out the greenery.
Whoa.
[Inaudible 00:02.06]
Alright this is gonna be very
blown out on this camera,
but we're gonna show
the process for firing
four flames of different
color into each other.
Who knows what this will look like.
Ready?
Yeah.
[Inaudible 00:03:46]
Get ready.
Three, two, one.
That was really cool.
That was awesome.
I really like that.
Yeah so like
I was surprised that you
could see the difference
in the colors and the flames coz.
Yeah especially between
the red and the orange.
Yeah yeah
Which,
you know, very similar.
In one of those shots you could see
the red got fired
slightly before the orange
and then the orange followed up
and there was a clear difference
between the two colors
And obviously the green
and the blue are just
really vivid and cool.
Yeah, I just really liked that.
I could watch that forever.
Find another new thing that I like.
I like colored flames.
[Inaudible 00:05:24]
Well hopefully you liked that video.
We have an artsy one.
But we'd have to blow stuff up every week.
Yeah, still don't do that at home.
Don't do that at home.
Even though it was artsy
it was still dangerous.
We set the ground on fire.
Yeah.
A few times.
And Dan set his hand on fire.
Oh God, not good.
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
Well, I was wearing gloves.
That's true.
So don't do it.
Yeah don't do it.
Feel free to follow us on Twitter.
Buy a shirt.
Do you have one?
Oh hang on.
Do you have one, do you have one?
Lovely.
I hate you.
And most importantly, as always,
subscribe to our channel
because we'll keep making Slowmo
as long as you keep watching it.